the big news of the day is that
Democrats in the House of
Representatives have announced two
articles of impeachment against
President Donald Trump it's happening
this is still merely the beginning even
though it feels like we are very far
into it including I mean we are dozens
and dozens of hours into live streams of
all sorts of different hearings but
still we are only now sort of getting to
the real meat of it this morning Nancy
Pelosi with an initial statement
followed by a Jerry Nadler chairman of
the House Judiciary Committee announcing
articles of impeachment followed by Adam
Schiff chair of the House Intelligence
Committee detailing the evidence for
each of those two and this is going to
be a big battle and it's going to be a
political battle importantly as much as
it is going to be a battle around the
evidence to articles of impeachment
charging Donald Trump the first article
is for abuse of power the president
Democrats say exercising powers of
public office to obtain improper
personal benefit while ignoring or
injuring the national interest what does
that mean in practice well this is what
they say Donald Trump did when he
solicited and pressured Ukraine to
influence our election and thus it is
impeachable because it violates his oath
say Democrats this will be now
adjudicated in a Senate trial assuming
the house votes to go forward consistent
with previous invites that Donald Trump
made in 2016 it was noted noted by Jerry
Nadler although that is not actually
what Donald Trump is being impeached for
and that is going to be a question mark
which is when the impeachment hearings
started there were assertions that they
should have included the emoluments
clause they should have included Trump's
dealings with the Yemen Fiasco that they
should have included some of the
obstruction that the Moller report
indicated Donald Trump participated in
but they don't and that is going to be
part of Democrats the Republicans
defense we will get to that a little bit
later now article
two is obstruction of Congress and that
actually relates to Donald Trump's
reaction when Congress started
investigating article 1 when the
impeachment inquiry was started Donald
Trump Democrats say engaged in defiance
of the inquiry which leads to another
impeachment article obstruction of
Congress Democrats said today that
Donald Trump by his actions when the
inquiry was announced declared himself
above accountability that the American
people were subjugated by Donald Trump
behavior that Donald Trump declared
himself above the impeachment power of
Congress which is a constitutionally
enshrined power and that is count number
two now Adam Schiff explained what the
evidence is and one of the things I like
about how Adam Schiff is approaching
this is that he made it about the
evidence tells us we must impeach
ignoring the political Sitter
considerations now there are political
considerations and I'm going to talk to
them but I have said from the beginning
that calculating whether the impeachment
process is likely to succeed or not or
how it is likely to affect the
Democratic primary those are perfectly
reasonable things to discuss but when we
are talking about something as serious
and infrequently used as not the power
of impeachment but the duty of
impeachment when the facts warranted
there should not be political
considerations and we're going to get to
that now Adam Schiff continued to lay
out the evidence that they have during
this morning's announcement pointing out
that Donald Trump solicited Ukraine to
publicly announce investigations into a
political opponent or or an expected
political opponent Joe Biden in order to
help his own campaign this is an abuse
of the power of the office of the
presidency and that to specific official
acts were conditioned upon at least the
announcement of those investigations
number one the release of military aid
to Ukraine and number two a White House
meeting for the Ukrainian president Adam
Schiff said this jeopardizes the
integrity of the 2020 election it
jeopardizes the integrity and
sovereignty of the United States to run
its own elections free from this type of
four
meddling and Adam Schiff claims to have
overwhelming evidence of all of this and
then laying out the evidence for count
number two obstruction of Congress that
once the news of the impeachment inquiry
or potential impeachment inquiry went
public that Donald Trump obstructed
Congress Schiff says he has all of the
evidence now one of the critiques all
along this entire thing this entire
inquiry and now the articles should
include Donald Trump's emoluments
violations emoluments Clause violations
I believe that that is absolutely
correct
and it is too late for that now and the
attempt to add anything in now whether
it's about 2016 interference other than
merely providing context or emoluments
or whatever else would be no question
seized on by Republicans to try to
discredit the entire thing saying look
it was about this and you said it was
about this initially and now you're
pulling in these other issues I think it
would be strategically a mistake
although politically there may be some
benefit to it Donald Trump immediately
starting to tweet including about the
USMC a this trade deal that he's been
talking about for a while also upon
learning that Democrats would be
announcing this today just before the
hearing started Donald Trump tweeting to
impeach a president who has proven
through results including producing
perhaps the strongest economy in our
country's history to have one of the
most successful presidencies ever and
more importantly who has done nothing
wrong is sheer political madness hashtag
20/20 election now what's important to
understand about this is that Donald
Trump has refrained has continued to use
this refrain time and time again at
rallies during interviews etc which is
how do you impeach a president who's
doing just such a good job and that is
exactly the misunderstanding about
impeachment that Donald Trump and many
on the right seemed to have impeachment
is not about from the point of view of
Democrats can we is this going to help
us or hurt us in 2020 what's this going
to do to Bernie and Warren if it pulls
them off of the campaign trail to be at
a Senate trial it is not about that it
is about what do the facts say given
what impeachment is supposed to be for
on the same along the same lines but on
the other side is this idea from
trumpets and from Republicans that if
the stock market is doing well the
president shouldn't be impeached that is
not what this is about that was never
what impeachment was meant to before and
that the continued either
misunderstanding or disingenuous
deliberate misstatement about the
parameters of impeachment is tricking a
lot of Trumpets into parroting that line
the economy is doing really well how is
it that you can impeach a president well
the two things have nothing to do with
each other so now what well now the
Judiciary Committee of the house is
going to meet they will examine the
articles and they will make a
recommendation to the house eventually
the house will vote now there was a
report this morning that that vote would
happen on December 12th
that's just 48 hours from now I don't
know if that still is the plan Jerry
Nadler didn't mention it during his
speech anyway we will see then we would
move importantly that requires only a
50% plus one vote in the house to move
forward we would then be moving forward
to a Senate trial there is speculation
that that could be in January as of last
week the Senate's calendar for 2020
starts in February they left January
blank presumably to account for the
possibility of the impeachment trial and
that could lead to a Senate impeachment
trial of the President of the United
States that wraps up just before the
first twenty twenty Democratic primary
votes start being cast on February third
in Iowa in the Iowa caucus and that's
where we start getting into the
political implications but it's
important to separate them we want to
separate the political implications and
possible repercussions of this
impeachment from the duty to do this
because the facts say that impeachment
is proper shift did this he explained we
won't get anywhere if we wait there were
arguments politically motivated
arguments about maybe it's better to
wait the timing could be better this
that the other time Adam Schiff pointed
out the White House has been ignoring
our requests it took months just to get
a
or to say that Donald Trump's attorney
Don McGann must testify it's still not
clear that the guy is going to testify
if he does he's going to assert
executive privilege and/or invoke his
Fifth Amendment right so that was well
said by Schiff saying let's wait is
saying let's let him maybe cheat again
in an election or let's let him cheat
one more time in an election and that
that doesn't make any sense Adam Schiff
rightly framing this as we're defending
the Constitution period that's what we
have to do impeachment has happened only
three times before Andrew Johnson and
Bill Clinton both of whom were acquitted
in the trials in other words with Andrew
Johnson and Bill Clinton the house said
via of a majority vote simple majority
let's go forward there was a Senate
trial and the Senate voted to acquit you
then had Richard Nixon Richard Nixon
resigned before the Senate trial of
course under the assumption the
overwhelming pressure that he was under
knowing that Republicans were going to
turn on him in the Senate because
Republican voters had turned on him and
he resigned to avoid ultimately being
convicted on impeachment so there has
never been an impeachment conviction for
a president in the history of the United
States
I don't expect there to be one this time
and we're going to get into that into
that we're gonna get to that in a second
the Senate trial which would be held
would be presided over by the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court John
Roberts and then you need 2/3 of the
Senate to vote to convict to remove the
President of the United States as of
right now and in January which will
still be the same Senate that means you
need 20 Republicans where does that math
come from there are forty-five Democrats
in the Senate there are two independents
Bernie Sanders and angus king who caucus
with the Democrats and would be expected
or at least for our math we should
assume they vote to impeach that's 47
you need 67 meaning you need 20
Republicans now in the most optimistic
case senator from Connecticut Chris
Murphy said as I told you yesterday he
knows of maybe a handful of Republicans
that would consider it
voting to convict Donald Trump even if
he's right and you get five even if he
gets twice as many and he gets ten
you're still short by ten so I don't see
this as getting Trump out via a
conviction but it does appear to be the
correct thing to do simply because it's
what the evidence says needs to happen
not necessarily what's most politically
advantageous now that being said let's
get to the political implications it
could be good for Democrats it could be
bad for Democrats a trump acquittal in
the Senate could completely reinvigorate
Trump and his followers who say he has
been vindicated after the Russia probe
and the impeachment hoax as they are
calling them and there may even be some
2016 Trump voters who still on paper
support Trump but they're kind of
disillusioned and maybe they were
planning on staying home it could really
reinvigorate the pro Trump electorate
and it could rock it Donald Trump to
re-election in 2020 that's one
possibility the other way it could go is
the Senate trial is devastating to
Donald Trump a couple of Republicans do
turn but not enough to convict Donald
Trump and it feels as though this guy
has again escaped the consequences and a
sense of justice makes people
invigorated to go out and vote for
somebody else that could also happen I'm
not feeling like it's hugely likely the
Republican response and strategy we
already know is an effective one which
is attack the entire thing as a
pre-planned farce Democrats decided back
in 2017 they were going to do this
there's no evidence the real story is
hunter Biden they will say it was all
hearsay which of course is both untrue
and misunderstands that hearsay is a
type of evidence remember these are not
criminal proceedings so that is a red
herring but those have been effective
strategies so far last thing political
implications for Democrats there's an
idea floating around that impeachment in
total like from the get-go
impeachment is an establishment
Democratic strategy to deny Bernie or
Warren their nominations possible
nominations as the Democratic nominees
the story being the Senate trial is
going to pull Bernie and Warren off of
the campaign trail at exactly the right
time
it'll tie them up and it will get Joe
Biden more attention it'll leave Joe and
Buddha jej and other establishment
candidates out there by themselves
without Burnie or Warren I don't think
that that would work number one since
Burnie and Warren being part of the
trial would get them likely lots of free
TV time that could help them
number two the trial is likely to happen
in the few weeks leading up to the first
caucus in Iowa and then they will again
be free to go and campaign as we
approach Super Tuesday in all of those
other days so I just don't think if that
is the strategy I think it's a pretty
poor strategy to deny Bernie and Warren
the nomination a lot here a lot going on
let me know your thoughts leave a reply
if you're watching on YouTube of course
after liking this video otherwise send
me a tweet at D Pakman follow me on
Twitter a lot of this discussion
happening there